[Musique]
bon alors je sais pas si dans c'est
comme ça au Moyen-Âge mais préparez-vous
à plonger dans un grand bain coloré en
plein cœur du Moyen-Âge qui n'est pas
une période triste en noir et blanc un
gué dedans l'alchimie des couleurs n'est
pas artificielle mais bien issu des
minéraux qu'offre la nature du site
bonjour Valérie bonjour Claire là c'est
l'équipe de la couleur c'est ça une
quinzaine de couleurs ici fait avec les
techniques du Moyen-Âge comment ça
marche on utilise des minéraux alors les
minéraux laisse-moi réfléchir me
rappelle parce que j'ai fait quand même
un petit peu de chimie au collège ocre
argile
hématite
c'est tout ce que j'ai au max alors on a
des pierres en fait pour résumer on a
des terres colorantes on a des sables au
creux ça veut dire qu'ils contiennent de
l'or et puis on a de l'argile
qui a été déjà extraite et que je vais
finir de broyer
donc ça veut dire que l'argile dès le
départ il a une couleur déterminée il y
a d'autres argiles qui font d'autres
couleurs oui c'est ça mais on a aussi
petit plateau là on a le même beige
qu'ici et juste à côté on a fait une
calecination ça veut dire qu'on a fait
cuire donc le fait de cuire on enlève
l'eau l'hydro on obtient un oxyde de fer
donc ça change de couleur alors
attention pas de danse
claire une fois qu'on a ça qu'est-ce que
vous en faites de la peinture parce que
là à ce stade là c'est un pigment donc
c'est une couleur de peinture ensuite on
va préparer la peinture seulement quand
on sait sur quoi on va peindre parce que
si on peint sur un mur ou sur du bois ce
sera pas la même recette alors sur du
bois ça peut être juste de l'oeuf de
l'œuf entier battu donc tu me dis que si
je prends ça je rajoute un œuf j'ajoute
de l'eau je mélange j'ai de la peinture
et oui donc ça veut dire que tous les
magasins où j'ai acheté des pots de
peinture des kilos de peinture il se
foutent dans ma gueule depuis les années
je viens d'apprendre une terrible
nouvelle
beaucoup d'argent dépensé dans le vide
alors Valérie tu me dis si j'ai bien
compris ici on est donc chez les
minéraux pour les peintures et il y a
les végétaux pour les teintures mais moi
ce que je peux rencontrer Madame
végétale
direction Charlotte la voisine
bonjour petite cascade pour arriver
impressionner
là je fais de la teinture jaune orangée
avec des pures d'oignons
que l'être humain fait de la ceinture
les sorcières là je crois que c'est ça
qui m'a attiré dans ce métier là en fait
sorcellerie
quand je vois toutes ces couleurs on
peut dire quand même au Moyen-âge ils
aimaient la mode le style la Fashion
Week plus les couleurs étaient vives
plus ça voulait dire qu'on était riche
la couleur des rois donc là en fait
c'est plus ou moins terminé ça va sécher
et qu'est-ce que tu fais de cette eau
qui reste alors je peux m'en servir
bah je peux rajouter des petits
ingrédients dedans tu vois là dans la
mare la jolie qui grenouille le soir
quand la nuit tombe quand elle danse bon
faut pas que les gens voient en fait je
vais en mettre quelques-unes dans mon
chaudron puis après tu vois j'ai des
petites baies un peu toxiques là-haut
parfois je vais chercher des petits
poils d'animaux dans la forêt voilà j'ai
pas de champignons là mais regarde il y
a un peu de lierre le lierre les belles
je crois qu'il est parti